all these is better than how bent
[Applause]
[Music]
Doctor Who series 12 episode 10 the
finale
the timeless children so I don't hate
everything about it actually if I were
to break down what I like and don't like
about it
I like the majority of elements in it
the majority of things that are in it
it's just that the things I don't like I
love will get there
that's spoiler talk I will start broad
and will avoid the spoilers for as long
as I can I will give you the heads up
so honestly I've got a lot to say good
things about I like the use of the
master I like the use of the Cybermen I
like some of the little things that get
dropped here and there with like little
acknowledgments of things that honestly
our fans have been saying this series
and I kind of fun yeah but I expected to
not really get acknowledged and some of
them did I'm like oh okay I'll probably
lay some of the specifics out a little
bit later the companions were solid I
think all the performances were good it
looked really good this whole series has
looked good like that I mean I was gonna
say that feels like it's almost not
special but it is the series has looked
good so props to that and the though the
way that the Cybermen story overlaps
with the master and the way that plays
out I thought was interesting and for me
that worked that worked fine there was
still good tension for both the
companions trying to get off the cyber
ship and then the ones on the ground who
were you know just trying to not get
killed the doctor honestly
doesn't have a lot to do which is about
the one criticism I can level at this
thing without getting into spoilers
because the doctor is kind of
effectively incapacitated for the
majority of the runtime of this thing
and just has and just basically sits
back as secrets are revealed she's not
the one uncovering them they're being
exposed to her by the master via the
matrix so it's not even something she's
discovering she's just she's she's just
an audience for the master to spew all
this stuff and again he delivers it
pretty well like here's the ultimate
thing and here's why I actually stand by
my comment what I said about it being
better than hell-bent because the thing
about how bent is that at its core it is
an idea that I feel is a bad idea that
you shouldn't do it all and then on top
of that it is executed really unevenly
and weirdly and awkwardly it was in my
opinion a bad idea poorly executed this
well first of all the thing that I think
is a bad idea isn't as core to the
entire episode the way the bad idea of
hell-bent was core to everything so it
actually does in the badness of the idea
it doesn't quite infect the rest of the
episode to the same degree as held back
so that's advantage number one but if a
number two is if you're if you're going
to do that idea this is a decent
execution of it in terms of how you're
gonna lay this out how characters are
gonna react to it for the most part
there's one issue I don't again come
back to it in spoilers and and things
like that it's it's a pretty good
execution of that thing you shouldn't
have done in the first place
so that is why I will easily say this is
still better actually I would say
significantly better than hell bent
because hell bent even after I finally
wrapped my head around what it was doing
cuz at first I didn't get it at all and
then I finally wrap my head around what
it's doing and thought about it more I'm
like okay not only was that not a thing
worth doing you did it really badly
this one it does a thing that I think is
a thing not worth doing but there's
nothing wrong with the execution of it
which is the idea but I I wanna I am
gonna start talking spoilers but I am
going to start by talking positive
spoilers because I know I know me once I
start getting on the thing that I don't
like I'm gonna stay on it
and I'm gonna get really ramped up and
talking about it so this is your warning
for spoilers coming here we go the
nature of the master sort of luring in
the Cybermen trying to negotiate with
them and then just turn around and
killing a shot and just taking the
Siberian I that works for me that is
that whole progression because I feel
like the the initial thing works as far
as the the master you know trying to
finagle some advantage out of out of
another species the master has a long
history of doing that and actually even
did it earlier in this series with wood
we saw that was by fall so like on board
for that
you know in a snap moment deciding you
have the Siberian I want the Siberian
okay you die now and getting rid of a of
a shot I that annoys me a little bit cuz
I actually really liked a shot I thought
it was a really effective villain but
he's also one of those bill villains
that I don't think was really built for
last ability he was a neat twist on the
Cybermen but I don't think it would have
worked having him keep coming back over
and over and over again so you know
having him be closed out in this story
that makes sense that works and in
addition to that sort of what I said
before about
like the little acknowledgments it gets
exhausting people brought up why are the
Cybermen trying to wipe out humans they
need them to convert what is going on
there and that kind of gets pointed out
because we find out Assad's whole thing
is he's got this death particle we're
gonna wipe out organic life and that is
like a point of order
you've got organic components how's that
gonna worries like we will purge
humanity and I'd like that like well
that makes sense but then like doesn't
that just mean that and then the master
says that well then you'll just be
robots there's nothing special about
robots robots are a dime a dozen why
would you do that so I kind of liked
that I kind of liked because it explains
some of Assad's motivations but then the
met the master of all characters got to
be the audience surrogate and go that's
a dumb idea why would you do that
and that's kind of fun it's fun when the
audience surrogate can actually be a
character who like your probably
shouldn't identify too much with like
the master so that was cool and I like
that I like Graham and yeah and those
people on that on that thing first of
all I like the moment between Graham and
yaws and there's sort of quiet little
moment of Graham being like you know I
think you're the most amazing person
I've ever met you guys just going yeah
you're pretty neat human you ever be
like that's it like a babble interaction
I enjoyed that a lot and I also like and
again it felt it almost felt like a
call-and-response between the episode
and well certainly me but I think your
standard audience for Doctor Who as well
Graham saying well we can put on these
outfits and pretend to be Cybermen and
somebody voices the thing that any
Doctor Who fan would there's human
remains in there well yeah well we can
clean them out it's not a great plan but
we can do it like what but III again the
acknowledgement that of the thing that
if they hadn't brought it up the fans
would have been all over the place about
it so again I liked that I liked that
the the dyspraxia for Ryan came up yo
him really nervous like I am a bad shot
and how celebratory was when he got that
bomb there
woosh or swish over the light forget
what he said you know in the net is like
like it was basketball and so happy that
was that was triumphant for him and I'm
I was glad to be able to enjoy that with
him so for all the things that are good
about this for all the things about the
presentation the performances the neat
little touches in the script the fact
that I think if this is the final
episode for these companions if that is
their exit I think it's a good one for
all of that I King hates everything to
do with the timeless child so I have
alluded to at a few points that I had I
saw a leaked thing that and I was hoping
to god that it wasn't true this is
exactly what it was so a little
background on this I had somebody bring
to my attention a forum like somewhere I
forget where it even was but somebody
had posted and it was dated prior to the
airing of fugitive of the Judoon and
they posted a series of not eating
predictions a series of things they
claimed to have learned about the story
this series and one of them was pretty
much exactly what went on with the
reveal of Ruth in
fugitive of the Judoon which lent some
credence to the other things this person
had laid out and one of the things they
laid out was the timeless child is the
doctor and timeless child was a being
found by the Gallifrey ins who could
just regenerate and they took their
ability to do that from this child and
it's the doctor
so I'm not even angry at this for law
breaking I am NOT a lore purist I never
have been especially with something that
can be as cleanly divided into eras as
this can be so for me in and of messing
with lore in and of itself while often
fraught is not an automatically damning
thing it's a question of what is the
impact of that lore alteration what has
changed what did you what did you undo
and what did you create because I think
I said this before any retcon is getting
rid of something and replacing it with
something else so it's a question of
what did we lose what it begain and from
that perspective I hate this because I
did a whole video talking about how I
don't like the doctor to have a big rep
reputation and the core reason why I
don't like the doctor to have a big
reputation as I don't like the idea of
the doctor being super important the
doctor is important to the people that
they encounter however they should not
be vital on their home planet
they should not be vital to the universe
this is part of why I already don't like
how central the doctor is to the time
war I can kind of deal with that because
unless you go out of your way to take in
a whole bunch of audios and novels and
whatnot you you don't necessarily have
to come face-to-face with that but I
like I'm going to default to how Capaldi
summed it up you know I'm not a
president I'm not a soldier I am an
idiot with a box and a screwdriver
passing through helping out that is who
I however the personality is
that is who I want the doctor to be
passing through and helping I do not
want the doctor to be super important
it's why during tenants run and he
literally he became so deified at
various points like in the last of the
Timelords like in voyage of the Damned
that annoyed the crap out of me it's why
with the eleventh Doctor it annoyed me
so much that his reputation was so big
that yes turning away armies at the
mention of his name that he kept showing
up places and people already knew who he
was that drove me crazy and now this the
only reason the Gallifrey UNS can
regenerate is because of the doctor
no no because now the doctor is not a
part of this society that they chose to
reject because they didn't share the
values of this society and they went out
and and struck their own path now the
society is a product of the doctor and
whether the doctor knows that or not
that's stupid that means that the Time
Lords don't even exist if it wasn't for
the doctor the fact that they did this
is the same reason that I was so happy
they never did the carbonelle master
plan which was going to apply that the
doctor have been involved in the in the
development like directly consciously
involved in the development of time
travel with Rassilon and Omega he was
going to be the other that was a stupid
idea back in the friggin 80s and they
never got to do it this is a stupid idea
in the exact same vein and of the same
order and here's the most infuriating
thing about me and the odd thing about
this is I realized that this element if
he rated me when at first I was like oh
well at least because I said earlier if
the doctor goes through this hole I
don't even know
I am anymore thing I was gonna get
really ticked off and she starts to have
that a little bit but she has Ruth
basically confront her the way I would
have wanted to confront her about that
being like yes you do you know who you
are you know what you are capable of you
know who you have been you get to decide
it doesn't get rewritten because of a
past you don't even remember so I'm glad
she told her that but here's where this
is infuriating to me that means that the
doctor is not going to change from this
revelation as a person as a personality
it's not going to change her approach
she basically got slapped upside the
head by Ruth you're the same person
which is good but if she's the same
person what was the [ __ ] point cuz
like I said the timeless child
revelations actually have almost no
impact on the entire rest of story it is
a completely in its own self-contained
bubble as though all the stuff going on
with the master and the Cybermen is all
going on none of that is impacted by the
timeless child revelations they're just
there they are completely encapsulated
around the doctor and they don't affect
the story so it doesn't affect this
story and the implication seems to be
that it's not going to affect her
personality or her approach going
forward so why did you do it it's a
stupid idea but if you're not even gonna
have it have a lasting impact why would
you do it at all even if you thought it
was a good idea what is the point if
nothing changes
other annoying thing I don't like how we
don't really get an explanation of how
the master single-handedly wiped out all
of Gallifrey that's actually kind of
bothering me like I could have bought it
the master having done that after
getting hold of the Siberian yeah sure
but like before just on his own how they
know the Matt like they know the Masters
dangerous but like how don't tell me I
don't care that much but like come on
this finale is really frustrating
because if I removed the timeless child
element which I can cuz it it doesn't
impact the narrative this is good
possibly even great it's well paced its
tense the escalation is good the ending
is a little bit I was a little annoyed
when that guy showed up he's like I'm
gonna because I was expecting yeas to
turn up it felt like they'd done all
this build-up of her being a bit
reckless and having that level of
bravery and so when it just turned out
to be this guy I'm like why um so like
that was a little bit and also like the
master is gonna come back and people are
gonna go what they need to explain how
the master gets that no they don't they
didn't explain how Davros came back
after the the cruciform or whatever it
was blew up they don't have to explain
why the master is gonna come back
eventually after this but
everything that wasn't the timeless
child was good to great with a couple of
nitpicks but the timeless child I hate
it I hate what it does for the
importance of the character and I hate
that they don't even appear to have the
balls to have it matter I'll be curious
to see where things pick up after this I
hope we'll see Ruth again I like Ruth
I'd not loving that they've basically
now opened the door for lack of a better
term Doctor Who prequels they basically
opened the door to be able to do
frigging enterprise or discovery
although I guess discoveries not a
prequel I don't know I don't watch it
but the door is now open we're at some
point somebody maybe not Chibnall but
somebody is gonna decide hey I want to
do a story where the doctor has less
tech less history less background
knowledge
oh I'll set it pre Hartnell you couldn't
do that with dr. hill before because he
was always the first doctor and I don't
like that the show now has given itself
license to get into that masturbatory
prequel nonsense
the this is this is what sunk Star Trek
for me for a long time and I don't want
to see it having the Doctor Who but I
feel like it's inevitable now and like I
say that and maybe by the time it
happens it'll just it'll just happen to
be a really good series or show where
they do it and I'll like it but like
right now conceptually I'm not happy at
all
Doctor Who the timeless children you've
seen it would you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about a bunch of stuff to do
support me on patreon if you want to do
something nice for my birthday
if you want to actually send me physical
stuff I've also got my Amazon wishlist
down in there cuz yeah it's my birthday
this month this episode almost felt like
present difficult for that one thing but
there you go plus the usual stuff like
subscribe share this around and all that
but I won't tell you what to do
cuz end of the day you're the council
I'm just trying the meanings and until
next time this council is exhausted yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]